hello everybody my name is markiplier
welcome to let's play evil now I don't
know much about it but it was released
earlier today or yesterday or whenever
was so like most games I don't know what
I'm getting myself into but let's find
out
by hitting plays and mean fear people
described it as a way of life others
trying to avoid it as they can I would
not describe myself as a coward I would
not even describe me as a person I just
remember getting up from my bed and have
made a big mistake hmm okay was that a
computer-generated voice that's what it
sounded like click to continue you got
it buddy
alright so this is made in unity engine
obviously as you could tell by the intro
and I've still got my mouse in here
don't know if you guys can see that oh
okay nice arm there buddy that's at 7:30
all right so I guess we're getting up
now
something ready for the day okay now I
can move I still got my mouse in here
that seemed to be a bit of a bug but
I've dealt with it before so we seem to
be in a house sounds like a beach house
not sure what we're looking for I hope I
don't have to click much because my
mouse is about to go out of here any
second now okay nothing there nothing
there nothing there
alright let's see if we can get outside
maybe no not there I can't leave yet
first I need to get dressed
haha okay alright I tried to click on
this dresser here oh now I'm ready to go
okay
righty-ho there buddy the handling
spinner no that didn't help my channel
okay whoa what that what this doesn't
seem like the other part of my house huh
this doesn't seem like the way to go to
work but okay this is slightly
reminiscent of cry of fear actually a
lot of the drawings that I saw reminded
me of some sequences in afraid of
monsters I can't seem to go any faster
than what I'm going right now
so uh I see two flashing dots I see yeah
see and afraid of monsters it's kind of
like the weird drawn levels that were
going on there that kind of kind of made
you very certain that you were going
insane that door handle is at a six
going to assume I can open this huh
wait a minute good morning
yeah haha okay so yeah it's thank you
7:30 not 8:30 7:30 thank you very much
okay do I need to get dressed again whoa
something has changed
I feel it in my loins okay yes normal
wait a minute
Oh what is going on holy hell
I've got my volume turned way up again
so I mean it's like what the hell is
under whoa what what why I was just
trying to go to work
whoa hello the hell are you house is
trying to have a nice calm relaxing day
at the office I did not ask for reality
to unravel on me seems to be trails of
blood some slight static walking towards
a glowing orb like thing not sure what
it is but here we go always good to walk
towards the unknown bright lights and
whatnot strange boxes that is kind of
very much reminiscent of afraid of
monsters the level sequences in there
very cool so far I love the environments
very very weird what is this what done
huh
oh I can jump okay good
oh that's that's where I was down there
how did I get up here I'm sorry I didn't
quite catch that you need to speak up
buddy oh [ __ ] I missed my window oh come
on come on come on come on
I need to get to that door over there
I'm assuming uh what the hell oh I was
walking on a face and now I'm floating
gently like a butterfly down what the I
did not realize they were giant faces
here hey that wasn't much fairness whew
they're kind of faces everywhere
okay this is getting kind of weird I
don't know why I fell through there
there I did not mean to sorry what was
that
you want to kill me you want to feed me
you wanna give me some oh hello again
okay so let's try to not fail but you
know me get ready for the jump cut of me
transitioning through this about 10,000
times what's that oh don't go for a net
okay here we go here we go hey ah ah
what the hell
Oh honky what was that alright wait
there seems to be a a path outside of
the moving parts let me let me try to
take that it was some sort of walkway
that I saw there and I'll figure this
out you saw I went right through the
thing might be bugs or whatever what
have you okay
carrying on looking for something up
still can't understand you friend okay
this way over here if I can get through
can I just walk through this good okay
it's a longer way but probably more
stable anyway hello ah Oh [ __ ] ah
bull bull bull bull alright ready for a
jump cut here ah mark ten minutes
BAM that's good level design right there
it took me ten minutes to get through
from there to there and all of this is
apparently a red herring because I kept
trying to go from here I got to that
platform right there before this long
bar I got on that one and I was I
couldn't literally could not jump up
from there to there I could not it's
preventing me the only way to go through
is through this side bar area and you
have to just get lucky just get lucky to
not have that thing push you off take it
very slowly and you'll get through just
fine other than that that's poor level
design just plain and simple poor brakes
the rhythm it's very hard to just
discern what the developer wants you to
do there's no clear objective and it
took way too long it broke all the
immersion you created good job okay so
continuing forward I'm not gonna let Bob
me down though I'm gonna keep at this
until I get to the end oh look wait what
God seems like this guy only has a very
limited set of textures
that just sounded like someone doing a
Monty Python impression whenever they
try to do a woman's voice Oh
what uh whoa hello what are you aren't
you just adorable
he's like some weird bug Syme assuming
it's an eye I'm looking at what is going
on here I mean in this game game there's
a lot of just moving forward with no no
clear objective as to what's going on it
kind of just tossed you into insanity so
I'm not exactly sure why or where how or
what I mean I'm getting the feeling it's
just a ramshackle oh hello that was a
face oh that's a face I'm looking at
what is this giant demonic turd
what hello okay it's definitely
interesting I'll give it that but uh
I think that voice happens when I turn
around it's quite annoying to be honest
not in the least bit whoa perspective is
a little wonky here please do please do
kill yourself
I would I would really much rather deal
with not listening to your voice at the
moment I don't know I really like the
perspective tricks they've got going on
here what the hell gonna
whatever you choose to do please do it
quietly ma'am or sir I'm not sure okay
anyway so the prospective thing that's
quite cool I like that a lot but um
what why what
ah
okay I guess this is creepy maybe huh no
I don't know what I'm looking at seems
just like a series of home movies I mean
admittedly they're rather bad home
movies but not not not not not all that
interesting actually
it's like I'm being force-fed into a
series of supposedly creepy scenarios
but they aren't actually all that creepy
and they aren't actually all that
interesting I mean I thought from what
the screenshots I was looking at the
level of design was going to be very
cool and the style and the art was going
to be interesting but I'm not even sure
what they're trying to accomplish here
this seems like something I would watch
if I was high on mushrooms or something
I mean it's not really an atmosphere
when there's this constant pulsing beat
in my ears and well I mean it looked
what the hell am I looking at here oh
you gotta be kidding I could have left
anytime I wanted to
balderdash hang on my mouse's okay
please yes please whoa high up go scream
at me
hi something wrong with your spine there
that is not appropriate to a human spine
oh wait no you got intestine so that's
just your esophagus okay I'll try this
door yeah anything
oh well hang on my mouse is all sorts of
wonky okay now what floating TVs hmm I'm
not
I mean this is cool this would be cool
by itself but only if there's a purpose
to it the reason why this the weird the
weird parts of cry fear were interesting
is because they were purpose for it he
was diving into the madness of Simon's
mind as he was projecting the monsters
and changing the environment around him
that was interesting this ah this this
is just madness for the sake of madness
you can't die
I didn't try and even if you want I
didn't really you can't yet yet you said
I can't die that was a those definitive
cannot but ok click you oh-oh click you
so good
Oh I'll click you like no one's ever
clicked you before ha ha
I'm cooking you ok I clicked you oh hi
what are you supposed to be
are you supposed to be scary hi again
what am I looking at here what am I
looking at you seem like your stitch
sticker Oh God
lady please thank you lady man sir
I don't know I don't know what's going
on with this game well that was loud but
what was the point
see I played games I played games before
where there were just a series of
screamers the Screamers by themselves oh
hi
slider man what the hell are you doing
in here why are you so big that's what
she said
seriously what that why why are you in
here this doesn't make any sense
your game you don't make any sense this
game does not okay what what oh not
another one of these not another one of
these I don't what is going on here that
sounds familiar I swear
that was it was at the beginning of nut
shirt I swear I've heard that in another
game oh god the terrible platforming
here we go let's see if I can scope out
a better path oh yeah yeah yeah I'm not
gonna make that jump okay yeah yeah
yeah I don't really know I mean I
haven't got much love to say I mean all
I've been doing is criticizing this game
I mean from the initial right from the
get-go I felt like something was off not
in terms of like hey this is kind of
creepy something is off I need to go to
the right not this way not in the creepy
sense that something was up but
something is off like something's off
with the design of the game like the
design of the game is inherently flawed
as far as I can tell I don't know if I
can make these jumps how they expect me
from get to point A to point B up I
almost didn't make that one look uh hell
what do you want from me oh god I'm not
gonna make this one haha [ __ ] C what is
this you kidding me what just happen
thank you thank you for doing that Oh
what that all right then I guess maybe I
was supposed to do that maybe I'm still
in purgatory maybe something going on
maybe something interesting gonna happen
up in these long corridors of stretched
textures some else gonna pop out of me
maybe I'm not exactly sure I love you
guys your joy that's because as far as I
can tell this isn't kind of a ride of
right of ill-repute
nothing interesting happening but just
me talking to myself
attempting to be I still want to know
why Slenderman was there why why you
can't just throw him into the game you
can't shoehorn him in like that and just
uh yes he's giant floating in the big
space I mean yeah the perspective things
you're doing a cool at all
oh no I'm trapped back into beginning
thing what was that thing that doing
this looks silly
oh no no no I don't uh I think I've I
think I've criticized this as much as I
can
there's okay enough please with the
beeping all right you know what enough
with the beeping all right so basically
the problem with the game is there was
no clear directive as to what was going
on the first place there's no reason to
the madness you can't just throw things
in a game and expect them to scare
someone
you can't build an app you can't have an
atmosphere without building an
atmosphere you just throw them into a
situation where the mechanics are kind
of slow and jittery and I mean things
look interesting but there's no rhyme or
reason there needs to be progression in
these type of games there needs to be an
explicit way and there's a lot of
interesting stuff in there I mean the
whole idea of the afraid of monsters
style stuff I'm actually kind of worried
that some of that might have been ripped
straight from afraid of monsters but I'm
not sure I won't blame I won't accuse
him that but I mean haha you can't just
do that to do it I mean I think a lot of
effort went into that game but it just
wasn't scary and that's all it was
trying to be was just trying to be scary
but anyway so hope you guys enjoyed it
this is my first extensive criticism of
game I mean this is the first time that
I've played a game and I have nothing
good to say about it I have absolutely
nothing good to say about this game
other than it looked like it had some
effort put into it but that's not really
a pro my cons list is huge so thank you
so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos I've done and
as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye it's every button on
and then suddenly it switched I don't
know how because I swear first every
button multiple times how did that how
did that happen how did that happen I
Jim please okay so that's processing